a lot of the
kind of the downfall of the the entire
organized crime a lot of it was due to
gotti's ego when you think about the
moves he made as far as getting to the
drug business it's like
you know listen but luciano even said
like we don't want to get involved with
drugs because that's that's what
attracts the attracts the fed yeah like
the drug was we don't need to do it you
guys are doing all this stuff you want
to get involved with the drugs and then
also you know you guys want to fly under
the radar he has 2 000 suits on he's
doing the interviews he's on the cover
of time you know it's like this you want
to be this celebrity so you're getting
all this attention so to me i know
people want us i think the easy out in
the way the media portrayed it is oh
sammy is the reason they fell like man i
would argue it was gotti i think he was
too wild and his narcissists and egos
after i left
i was with the government for quite a
while i was living in quantico it's a
military base that they had me put there
and
they told me john was a blessing
oh yeah i said what do you mean
he gave us the entire mafia all five
families the whole thing the whole
on a silver platter
because the recordings at the the courts
and recordings because of the way he
dressed yeah the news media but also he
had everybody come kiss his ring yeah
like every every once a week they'd have
to come to the rape night club the whole
the entire every everybody who was made
and come and say hi on the street but
that's the other thing yeah the fbi is
like yeah but that but they're not going
to bust them off that but the raven
knight but who he is no
he didn't care about that b the raven
nightclub was bugged and they knew it
but he would still go upstairs and talk
about it
yeah that's a huge issue yes i'm saying
that so many of these guys the fbi
correct me if i'm wrong sammy didn't
they didn't they didn't even know who
they were but until they had they came
out and now you're kissing john they
were like well that guy's a that guy and
that guy and they just
wasn't an important guy we know he was
there but if he wasn't important enough
that he was just doing his thing he's
under a captain
you're never going to see that guy he's
not a well-known guy he's not going to
go sitting with the boss
what this did was take those guys who
would never even really known we knew
who they were but not the government now
they're going there and reporting like
he's saying kiss the ring not actually
kissing the ring but they're coming in
now they're grabbing me
and they're telling me sami
bro i i
they don't this is and they never had a
picture of me now i'm walking in i see
guys with cameras the news is here the
government is here what are we what is
he doing yeah talk to him please
i said i did i did he's the boss
whatever he wants i i i did talk to him
i grabbed his brother jeannie gene gotti
and i said to genie i said gene
go over his house at night you're his
brother you're a friend of ours he was
actually a captain
so i says tell them that all the old
times everybody's complaining this this
is insane what we're doing
he says sammy i did that
and what did he tell you
he said when you want to talk to me
about mommy or the kids or people you're
my brother come and talk to me you want
to talk about girls in austria go
through sammy oh wow
i said he told you that
yeah
so so listen to the story listen to how
machiavellian gotti was guys it's crazy
but i'm going to talk to i was telling
him a story i'll tell you the story that
when the guy from the genovese people
said about the
you you can't do a job unless you get a
wink of a nod from sammy another guy
came in a captain from the columbo
family
and said
john
i was at tally's last week on tuesday
sammy does his books and meets his guys
and other people and
i went there with 60 [ __ ] guys there
made guys captains under bosses union
bosses
this guy is a [ __ ] powerhouse he's
become
now that struck john in a way
hmm he's doing a lot of work
i'm sending him on missions
he wants to take me out he could take
over tomorrow
with the power that he has now
so he's trying to undermine me that's
the tapes he got caught on
and he's telling frankie lucasio to go
out basically and tell the captains
sammy lost his mind bro he's killing
[ __ ] people taking over their
businesses he's killing people taking
over the unions both of them not true
and i'll tell you the reason why because
you can't just kill your underboss
if he's liked if he's loved he's
bringing in money to the family he's
doing work
now what makes it even stronger is that
he's sending me on hits to get things
done as the underboss
you stop that at the captain level yeah
ozzy on the bus i'm going on the street
so you guys have to hit
he tells me shammy go with that make
sure it gets done
john i'm the underboss bro i did that
you know i'm up on a whole nother level
now god take you got you got to go there
get this done
okay
so i go
now you two guys when i'm not around you
were talking and some guys got caught on
tape
oh my god this [ __ ] sam man just
sitting on his [ __ ] ass giving orders
he's on the street with a gun with us
these don't work they love you for that
yeah and he see john forced that
situation
so when i come into the club you guys
are sitting there you jump up you see
hey see me yes you love me for what i'm
doing yeah i'm not just sitting i'm i'm
one of you yeah they respected it i'm
getting the respect so that's where this
all created he created it basically
himself
and then
all my ways i guess and so now he's
starting to spread rumors that i'm doing
this thing because he has a plan to take
me up
but it's so silly because you're such a
big earner right right because if you're
making so much money you know and
obviously that's where his ego
narcissism comes in because making him
so much money but
it don't matter because he's making
millions and millions of millions so
what's when you're making five or ten
million a year what's the difference one
minute yeah less
but uh the important part is
now he's starting to worry that i could
kill him to take over
now were you thinking about that be
honest oh no absolutely no i wasn't in
your head never never
never
why
why because i why would i do that yeah
we took over the family together me and
him it's us against the world frankie
the chico died i didn't want him as the
boss originally but that's a whole
nother story yeah let's do one at a time
yeah